aujourd'hui c'est amy verdez faire une
vous êtes le web j'aimerais faire une
petite déclaration c'est possible
j'aimerais voir alesi aussi pour soi
même rejoindre là oui bien sûr
maintenant voilà cyril ma petite chicha
j't'aime comme on aime celui qu'on a
cherché éternellement jusqu à le trouver
à ouarzazate
cyril tu es mon coeur tu es mon ami tu
es mon millésime ma plus belle année
cyril c'est pour ça que j'aimerais te
demande est là devant les
téléspectateurs avec tout mon amour avec
toute ma passion avec tous vivent des
vies dans extraordinaire et dans le ça
veut rien dire j'ai pas essayé
est-ce que cyril mon petit couscous
royal
tu aimerais qu'on reprenne tous les deux
stoppée at-on atteint une force te plaît
pas trop radin les parents parlent
direct je veux bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]